1620, the Mayflower docked at a port in southern England.
Puritans found it hard to adapt to the United Provinces, no matter how welcoming.
Fiercely independent, they decided to leave for Virginia, that new land in America,
where the London Company, under the guidance of John Robinson, installed its first settlers.
And our Lord God, who is watching and guiding us, he will aid us.
In your mercy for us, he will start.
Really now, you don't need to care.
Make way.
Will you move on?
Make way, I want to go through here.
Faster. Good for nothing. Faster.
Can't you do anything right? Hold on.
Hey, but you think more of this thing is cruel.
You're an idiot. Not very smart. Putting yourself right in our way.
You better watch out. You're in our way.
And what about all my things? I'm losing my temper. I've had it now.
Hosanna. You are in the highest. I have pity on us.
I'll never get him all on board.
Keep moving. Keep moving. Keep moving. Come on. Come on. We're going to miss the boat.
Step on it.
But you were after us.
What? I'm boarding the boat first.
You won't be boarding before me.
I'm getting mad now.
Just wait your turn.
There'll be places for everyone.
So what?
Let's go by here.
Oh, well, of course.
But of course, go on.
You're ahead of me.
Come on, let's go.
You ought to speed well.
Do you have any room for two more and a couple of things?
I'll pay well.
Well, get on board.
To Paul.
Can't we pay for America?
Well, why don't you roll?
What?
Roll away to America?
No, I didn't mean just to the Mayflower.
Of course. You see my baggage on there? Where is that?
Uh, well, Chief, we can send them.
Wait, don't go with me. Wait for me.
91, 92, 93, 94, 95, 96, 97, 98.
Hey, someone's missing. Should be 102. Hold on, count again.
97, 88, 89, 19, 91, 92, 3, 94, 95, 96, 97, 28, 99, 100, 101, and 102, all here now.
Thy symbol of your grace will become a remedy for our salvation.
Salvation.
Oh, man.
That time, all were accounted for.
The Mayflower could set sail toward her destiny, an unusual land toward which the Pilgrim Fathers of the Mayflower were setting sail.
30 or 40,000 years before our time, the forefathers of the native people came by way of Siberia in a long migration, which brought them to the new continent.
Some of them went as far as Patagonia, others settled near the Great Lakes in the north.
There were one million living there when the Europeans arrived.
Oh, pretty young girl.
One million for a territory that was 17 times the size of France.
and buffalo 60 million buffalo they provided the indian with all his needs meat to feed him
skins to clothe him ligaments for his bow strings and bones for his arrowheads see not far from here
on the great sea a boat that is greater than ours full of white men what do you mean by white men
well their skin is all white and what do you like what you're telling us are they bad men are they
strong like that they're only little here on our land on top buffalo would surprise me they don't
look like hunters they are they look like like that we should go and look at the white men we
have no food what are we going to eat i don't know nothing at all charlotte who shall be the turkey of
the fires and sent by satan well no no it's the lord god who sent it to us for the full satisfaction
of his faithful hmm hey hey there like to know who you are and what does all that mean yeah i'd
like to know too it means that these kids are only savages they're red look at this
november 1621 from these days of celebration originated thanksgiving day 90 indians were
present but after this fraternization there was to be no easy understanding between these two
divergent cultures with 10 000 years between them and the taste for conquest of some clashed with
the basic desire to settle of the others america was soon to see expansion tell the truth there
were explorers before the mayflower who came to the shores of america the vikings with eric the
red in the 10th century on october the 12th in 1492 when columbus discovered america that america
was to become the cause of some misunderstanding.
First of all, it was on an island in the Bahamas that Columbus landed.
Inspired by Marco Polo and thinking he had discovered India,
he called the natives Indians.
Several years later, tired of the dispute who named that part of the world,
the discovery of America is attributed to Amerigo Vespucci,
an explorer who landed a few kilometers to the south.
And so we have America.
And that's how history is written in geography.
The first state was to be Virginia, discovered in 1585 by Sir Walter Raleigh.
But it is in 1607 that three ships will bring the first immigrants.
It is the very same ships that wanted to join the Mayflower and became lost and ended up in Cape Cod.
You're going to turn towards the south, you understand?
But why? This land is a good place to land.
You can come along with us.
Captain, I'm not going to repeat it.
Lift the anchor and lift it quick.
Well, now look here, do you think?
Enough, enough, enough.
Now then, when you're making me nervous, I won't do it at that time.
and reside with you in the unity of the holy spirit so be it as the immigrants in virginia
settle in further north the frenchman is founding quebec his name is samuel de champlain and he
sees to the development of a city allied with the hurons he explores the country colonizes it
unfortunately the frenchman's native country is fertile and he doesn't want to emigrate to a harsh
land 50 years later there's still only 2 000 in canada of which 800 are in quebec and their
Heroism does little to increase their number.
During that time in America, we get Plymouth, Providence.
In 1626, a Dutch sailor, Peter Minuit, buys Manhattan Island from the Indians for $24.
And so New Amsterdam is born.
That wall will later be called Wall Street.
In 1664, an English regiment led by the commander, the Duke of York, approached the city.
The governor of that city was a hearty lad, a peg leg, Peter Stuyvesant.
No more munitions.
Thought of munitions, Peter Stuyvesant had to surrender.
New Amsterdam became New York.
In 1663, the Carolinas were founded, land of cotton and landed aristocrats.
You've made a good deal. Look at that.
In 1665, New Jersey appears on the map and develops.
I see that no one's followed my instructions.
Everybody's a bot. Change that.
In 1681, in payment for a debt, the young William Penn was given a vast territory by King Charles II.
It was to become Pennsylvania.
Georgia philanthropically welcomed the poor of England.
It was founded for this reason in 1732.
No slaves, no alcohol.
That was to be the moral code.
At least at the beginning.
All the colonies grew accidentally.
Chance, climate, the nature of things, individual temperament were deciding factors.
But there was a long way to go before those scattered colonies were to become fused into one nation.
The 13 colonies ran along the coast to an inland depth of 100 to 300 kilometers.
To reach farther, they would have to deal with the Indians.
Yes, at first, everything went fine.
Me listen.
Perfect.
When you sell us part of your territories, you'd be well paid, huh?
What do you say, huh?
Understand me?
You want us to sell our land?
Hmm, let us think.
Huh.
Yeah.
Hmm.
Ha ha ha.
You want our land? But what for? Very curious idea.
And why not also you buy our water and our rivers, the clouds in the sky, the fire?
Well, why not buy? Because they are for everyone.
Why don't you take whatever you need?
Uh, oh.
Well, you great chief to seal our new agreement with you.
Here's some good water of life.
And so that's that.
Huh? Your new land is over here. It's an excellent investment.
Hear that.
Well, no, that's that. I've the impression I got myself a good deal.
Indeed. So we won't get wrong.
Okay. Come on. Cool down. We're joking around a bit.
You just keep karma, pretty, and don't run off, girl.
They do such a thing. Yeah. In a quiet neighborhood.
Without any doubt, business wasn't too good in that part of the country.
Let's get out of here.
In 1760, the Europeans number one and a half million, and growing very fast.
New York, Philadelphia, Boston already added up to 200,000 souls,
while a healthy middle class showed signs of their own dreams.
Great Britain, drained by the Seven Years' War, decided to hit the colonies hard with taxes.
The colonies were made to pay taxes and income tax.
Then grew back at first, then continued.
Continue, I propose a tax on the tea, huh?
And voted taxes on diverse articles. One was tea.
Come on, dump the cargo into the sea.
Two hundred sons of liberty disguised as Indians in 1773 threw overboard a cargo of tea that had been taxed.
In Philadelphia, one year later, they held their first colonial congress,
where it was said all men have the right to liberty and to property.
They've never ceded to any sovereign the power to dispossess them of one single belonging without that man's consent.
February the 2nd, 1775, in the Parliament in London, Massachusetts declared itself in a state of rebellion.
It was agreed to blockade the colonies.
Already after the Boston Tea Party, George III had said,
This time, the dais cast, the colonies must submit or conquer.
Then on, that was their task.
Admiral Gage, commander of the English regiments in Boston,
wasn't yet aware that the War of Independence had begun.
Rebels really want, they didn't really know,
and they wouldn't while they were still drunk with liberty.
To declare them rebels, proceed from one mistake to another.
The English were pushing them towards the only issue, that of independence.
I'm for the English.
The English are a pleasure.
I'm marching with them.
What do you say, eh?
I have the courage of my convictions, my goodness.
A collaborator.
All right. Well, if that's the way it is, I had you...
June the 15th, 1775, George Washington is appointed commander of the American troops.
There was such a shortage of everything that Franklin even foresaw the use of bows and arrows.
Two days later, the 17th of June, 1775, was the raid on Bunker Hill.
Fire!
A year later, June the 11th, 1776, a committee is appointed to draw up a Declaration of the Rights of Man.
The authors: Franklin, Sherman, Jefferson, Livingston, John Adams.
The text. We hold these truths to be self-evident, that all men are created equal, that they are endowed by their creator with certain inalienable rights, that among these are life, liberty, and the pursuit of happiness, that to secure these rights, governments are instituted among men, deriving their just powers from the consent of the government.
The outcome of armed combat is not always predictable, but the English General Howe refuses to negotiate until the Declaration is abolished.
On October the 17th, 1775, the English troops are defeated at Saratoga, and it is then that France jumps at the chance to revenge itself with a seven-year's war.
It allies with Franklin in a treaty and gets into the conflict, bringing the heavy support of the regiments of Lafayette and Rochambeau and the French Navy.
October the 19th, 1781, the English are defeated at Yorktown.
The English General O'Hara walks towards the French commanders Lafayette and Rochambeau to surrender.
But the Frenchmen direct him towards an American officer whose uniform is not quite as remarkable as George Washington.
Their independence is recognized in 1783, and the United States will gain considerable territory.
1803 Louisiana sold by France, 1819 Florida, 1820 Maine, 1845 Texas, 1846 Oregon, 1848 California, Nevada, Utah, Arizona seeded by Mexico.
Coming from Ireland, Germany, England, immigrants flood in by the millions.
And the population jumps from 3 to 25 million.
Since it was difficult to settle in the coastal cities, there was the migration to the west.
What are you doing in my wagon? Keep it moving!
The Indians hunted down and chased off their territories were not always so easy to handle.
One day in January 1848, a young man, James Wilson Marshall, accidentally makes a discovery.
As soon as the news spread, it was the Great Rush, Great Gold.
There's feverish activity around the Gold Territory.
Our good friends decide to go south.
The south alone is almost as big as Europe.
Six million white men, three million black men, slaves.
For centuries, torn away from their native Africa, treated like objects.
In spite of the law in 1808 forbidding slave trading, the import slave trade is as brisk as ever.
In Virginia and Maryland, black men were bred like cattle for slavery.
In the North, there was more and more vehement slavery.
The South reacted by moving towards self-government.
Delicate balance between the Northern and Southern states would soon be broken.
President Lincoln made hopeless injunctions for unity in the nation.
12th of April, Fort Sumter was attacked by the South.
That was to be the first act of the war of secession during which the stature of Abraham Lincoln would grow